au cours du dialogue on avait très envie
de se rencontrer comme ça arrive souvent
c'est sûr surtout que m'avait parlé de
bon de quoi
[Musique]
donc c'est mona c'est d'ailleurs le même
que mon prénom qui émane a aussi se noua
zappé ce qui veut dire non pas parce à
l'envers mais elle soulève possible
claudia larsen parce que où l'effet
larsen maman tu vois ma tête je veux pas
bas prix marie rose mais parce que
j'avais permis de rencontrer des gens
que s'ils ne pourraient pas rencontrés
dans je dirais dans la vie réelle en ce
moment ça m'amuse et puis c'est marrant
c'est un plaisir ton boulot tant bistrot
quand tu veux provoquer des gens n'en a
pas il y en a qui drague est vraiment c
est bon la doc qui donne comme moi
rachid tellement je me suis aperçu
qu'avec certains mots certaines phrases
certain ton on arrivait à faire
tellement rêvé l'autre de l'autre côté
qu'au bout de deux trois quatre jours
ils tombent amoureux sans nous avoir
jamais vu ça fait travailler
l'imagination c'est incroyable il ya des
histoires d'amour fantastique sur le
minitel on arrive quelquefois aller à
l'essentiel avec quelqu'un parce qu'il
n'ya pas tout le reste il a juste les
mots - 3 août va chercher femmes belles
choses
c'est un engin du diable sont classés
non c'est pas dangereux c'est pas c'est
un outil un outil n'est jamais dangereux
qui c'est c'est très dangereux
on a vraiment eu droit suicidé quelques
mois on a eu droit des mariages ou six
qui est aussi dangereux que le suicide
de mon avis je dis pas que si on ne
connaît pas le minitel on va mourir
idiot pas du tout mais disons que c'est
une chose qui parle quand même apporter
quelque chose c'est évident
[Musique]